a source has new details about khloe
kardashian's life as a mom of two i just
want to live my life and be happy yeah
and she wants to keep things civil with
ex tristan thompson i wish we could have
one boring day in this family
as et's insider tells it chloe's quote
doing well
and she's quote trying to gauge the
dynamic of her relationship with tristan
but that will come in time right now her
focus is on her baby
hello my name is tripp chloe and
tristan's daughter true became a big
sister last month after they welcomed
their second child a son via surrogate
for now et's source says things between
the exes quote are mostly positive and
cordial as they work quote through some
hurdles exactly
but overall the two are hopeful and
confident that they can continue to
co-parent in a healthy way and give
their little ones the best lives
possible everything is an act of
betrayal everything is a lie everything
is
manipulation fans will recall how chloe
and tristan's fallout capped off season
one of the kardashians did tristan have
every opportunity to tell me yes was
tristan going to tell me if there wasn't
a baby involved absolutely not and that
shows a lot about his character the
entire thing is despicable fast forward
a few months we got a glimpse of how the
series will chronicle chloe's second
bundle of joy i wish we could have one
boring day in this family
yeah no such luck this time coco season
two is gonna be insanity we got this
we're built for this our family grows
first kylie now chloe it's gonna be
really exciting and i am ready the sneak
peek comes amid chloe opening up about
her new chapter as a reality star tells
l magazine chloe loves everything about
motherhood quote even the hard parts
like protecting what her kids read
online ain't nothing pretty butterface
chloe says quote we have to take those
roles seriously especially in today's
day and age with how much accessibility
children have and the information
they're exposed to so young
some of that information might include
chloe's dating life which et's learned
tristan has some thoughts about quote
tristan is jealous about chloe dating
and wants chloe to himself but he also
wants to play the field and knows he
can't have the best of both worlds i
don't know true's getting older and i
just feel like it's now time
to have another kid
yup
i like to hear
yeah it's definitely what true wanted to
hear too the source adds she's quote
obsessed with her little brother and
considers this a quote dream come true
for her
[Music]